Denis Hutchinson co-editor of the
Forgotten memoir of John Knox who was he
John Knox was a law clerk to justice
James McReynolds during the 90 1936-37
term of the Supreme Court of the United
States and late in life he decided to
write a memoir of that term because it
has it turned out it was really the high
point of his life so he spent 11 years
writing up that one year and when he was
done he had 978 manuscript pages and he
tried for years and years to get it
published and whole or in part and he
failed and when he died in 1997 he left
behind multiple copies of the manuscript
I came across several chapters of a
manuscript in our law school library at
the University of Chicago where I worked
and that made me curious as to where the
rest of it was because this is basically
a unique artifact law clerks don't write
memoirs about working for the Supreme
Court and then I discovered that David
Garrow at the Emory Law School had a
complete set of the manuscript which he
discovered while he was working on his
book on Roe versus Wade so I called him
up and said he wanted to a joint edition
we'll see if we can convince somebody to
publish it and he thought it was a great
idea because Knox is surviving cousin
who was the legacy of the literary
rights to the book had been pushing
David to get it in print he had other
projects I was fresh off of a book so
that's what I started doing three
summers ago why should somebody read
something like this it gives an insight
into how the court operated between the
wars it gives an insight into what
Washington's society was like between
the wars which was very formal very
southern and it's human izes an
institution that we usually see only in
soundbites or our discussions you tell
us said James C McReynolds Justice of
the Supreme Court had been the Attorney
General appointed by Woodrow Wilson
Woodrow Wilson why did he send him to
the court well the rumor always was that
McReynolds was so difficult to deal with
at meetings that's once there was an
opening on the court Wilson was glad to
be rid of him I think that's true in
part if not completely but Wilson
admired his work as a trust Buster
McReynolds indeed had come to Washington
as an assistant attorney general in the
Theodore Roosevelt administration that's
how he came to Wilson's attention
McReynolds served on the Supreme Court
from 1914 to 1941 what was he like
nasty racist anti-semitic gratuitously
cruel fixed in his ways and lazy how do
you know that from a combination of
what's Knox has written and from almost
every other account you can find
including half dozen unpublished PhD
theses about the man based on interviews
with people who knew him and where was
he from originally from Elkton Kentucky
border area Kentucky Tennessee and he
grew up in a very strict household
disciples of Christ the Campbell light
wing his father was known as the Pope
not for his Catholicism but for his
infallibility at least in the community
he was a very severe man and his
anti-semitism is notorious for example
there's no photograph of the court in
1924 because he would have had to sit as
protocol required next to justice Louis
Brandeis was a Jew and he wouldn't do it
when justice cardozo Benjamin Cardozo
was being sworn in Justice McReynolds
was reading a copy of the Washington
Herald
on the bench you do have a photograph
here it doesn't say what year it is I
don't know it's it's the year that John
Knox clerked at the court the October
term 1936 I don't know whether we can
get any closer or not but I want our
audience to see the photographs if you
look in that picture all the way over to
the left is Louis Brandeis that's
correct
in the back
way over to the right is Benjamin
Cardozo correct and McReynolds justice
right there in the front row second from
the right second from the right that's
correct so he is standing more or less
in front of Cardozo but at least he
doesn't have to sit next to me who else
is in this picture from the 19 what year
unite in 1936 1937 the front row as
Justice Brandeis next to him as justice
Willis Van Deventer in the center as the
Chief Justice of the United States
Charles heaven shoes then McReynolds
then Justice George Sutherland back row
justice Owen Roberts justice Pierce
Butler stone Harlan Fiske stone and
Cardozo so a lot of little things the
court at that time sat where it had just
moved in to the new building at one
First Street northeast that we think of
as being the Supreme Court and always
been there but it had only opened in
1935 after being on the drawing board
for a long time so this was only the
second year of the building's operation
the justices though were very set in
their ways on the whole and by and large
and they tended still the work out of
their homes indeed only two members of
the court actually used the new building
that was Chief Justice Hughes and
Justice Roberts the rest of them had law
libraries in their homes they had one
staff member usually a couple of them
had to knock served as effectively both
a law clerk and as a social secretary
part of his job was to answer
invitations to social functions for the
Justice as well as to assist him doing
research on court work one of the things
I thought when I was reading the diary
that there were a lot more cases oral
arguments heard then and there are now
like last session here there were 75 how
many were heard back then you know well
that's that has varied from time to time
it was really was about the same but
there were far fewer petitions for
certiorari that is threshold applica
patience for the court to hear cases are
they numbered in the hundreds then they
number about 7,000 what was the
political makeup at the court in 1936
well putting to one side parties because
McReynolds was a Democrat appointee from
Woodrow Wilson but he was very
conservative the so-called four horsemen
as they were a pathetically called
justice Sutherland justice Van Deventer
justice Butler and Justice McReynolds
were just rock-ribbed conservatives who
thought that the New Deal was straight
out of hell as well as being
unconstitutional was a recipe for
socialism and they were going to stand
in the way at every point along the way
on the other side of the spectrum you
have justice Cardozo whom we mentioned
justice Stone and Justice Brandeis who
were more liberal by common denomination
and more willing to let the government
try to deal with the horrors of the
depression massive unemployment problems
with wages prices and the like and then
there are two figures in the middle
chief justice Charles Evans shoes and
justice Owen Roberts and depending on
where those two justices go and Roberts
is really the linchpin he's the one who
changes during this term if the New Deal
is going to be constitutional and is
going to run or it's going to face one
roadblock after another and up until the
spring of this term Roberts had stuck
with the four horsemen and he switched
in the spring and that's the so-called
switch in time that saved nine because
at that point President Roosevelt had
proposed making the judiciary more
efficient by being able to appoint one
justice for any justice seventy years of
age or older
that would have increased the size of a
court to fifteen is that actually where
that saying came from absolutely a
switch in time that's a nine that's
right kept the court at nine now in 1936
Franklin Roosevelt was president what
was the world like that
well Roosevelt had just finished his
first
term and as the first term war on the
Supreme Court was striking down various
aspects of the New Deal such as the
Agricultural Adjustment Act the National
Industrial Recovery Act the bituminous
coal Conservation Act of 1935 on grounds
that either Congress lacked the power
because it wasn't interstate commerce or
that the states had the power under the
Tenth Amendment to regulate these
affairs and the federal government did
and was driving Roosevelt crazy and he
thought that it was an affront to his
political authority and it was a poor
reading of the Constitution but he
couldn't do anything about it during his
first term because there were no
vacancies on the court like the Jimmy
Carter he went through a full term
without being able to point a buddy at
the court nine justices how many of them
were over seventy six were seven years
of age roll and go back to the FDR
proposal on the court packing anybody
any justice seventy years of age or
older who does not retire can have
essentially a new seat will join him on
the court John Knox was his secretary
his clerk during this very absolute
ridin year that's exactly here's a
photograph of him when he was seven
where was he when he was seven years old
Oak Park Illinois he grew up in the near
western suburbs of Chicago his father
wrote and published how-to books for
travelling salesmen where did he go to
school John Knox himself went to the
College of the University of Chicago he
went to the Northwestern University Law
School in Chicago
where he took his initial law degree and
then he did two years of a graduate
degree at Harvard Law School and where
did you get these photographs for the
book I was able to trace down his last
caregivers neighbors when he was
decrepid and ninety who had stored
material for him and this is the classic
archival historians adventure crawling
around in the basement of a house and
having somebody say there's a box of
material you might want to take a look
at that
whereas these where are these groups of
photos here there with a hat on what the
Hat on is when Knox was serving as a
guide during the World's Fair of 1933
which also became the World's Fair of
1934 it was so successful and he's a
young guide and he's basically just out
of law school and then photographed next
to the ones in the Hat are Knox's
greatest Knox's graduation photo from
the northwestern law school what was he
like as you can tell that's best I can
tell he started writing celebrities when
he was a teenager I think he was I read
2,000 pages
it was diary handwritten typewritten
typewritten
starts out from a handwritten notes and
then as reduced to typing is this this
that's his diary for 1938 and that's
stage one of his recollections on a
day-by-day basis he would make notes of
what happened of conversations and the
like and then in the evening around the
weekends he would elaborate them in
typewritten form is this what the diary
look like 436 the diary 436 has been
lost all we have is fragments of type
writing for that period did he did he
keep a daily diary he kept a daily diary
I think until 1939 as best as I can tell
you had these photographs was Oliver
Wendell Holmes who's in them the
photograph on the left is Holmes and
Knox it's the summer of 1930 as I was
saying even as a teenager before he went
to college he right away to celebrities
particularly those who had served in the
Civil War he was fascinated by romance
and valor of fighting and Holmes of
course was a civil war veteran had been
wounded three times during the Civil War
I noxious thinking of going to law
school so Oliver Wendell Holmes was a
twofer
so he wrote Justice Holmes and
volunteered to drive to Beverly farms
Massachusetts from
Chicago the visiting and Holmes
apparently couldn't think of a good
reason to say no so we let him come and
had lunch and talked about the Civil War
though not very extensively the Knox's
regret the other photograph there on the
right is of Holmes and his law clerk for
that year Alger Hiss were you surprised
to find this I was astonished to find it
why
usually when archival historians rid
around in basements looking for
long-lost treasures they don't find
anything it's either been carefully
taken care of or it's lost forever
was there a relationship ever between
John Knox and Alger Hiss there was a
social relationship during the year that
Knox clerked at the court it wasn't very
extensive
I think Knox was very lonely by his
admitted account in the memoir the year
that he served in Washington he chafed
under working for McReynolds who we
found cold and distant and very
arbitrary and he can refire his
acquaintance ship with Alger and
Priscilla his but as far as I can tell
from his account they didn't see each
other more than two or three times one
odd thing that I thought was interesting
was he he got to know G Mennen Williams
the former governor of Michigan exactly
right what was he doing then well there
are lots of bright young folks who came
to Washington during the New Deal and
Williams was in this circle that Knox
kind of stumbled into unwittingly and
they got very nervous about but they're
all new dealers and they centered around
quick Newton who later became president
of University of Colorado mayor of
Denver and at that time was working for
William O Douglas at the Securities and
Exchange Commission
why was he nervous why couldn't he be
with the new dealers because he was
working for the most arch-conservative
on the Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court at so you know socially you know
you're out you're not one of the boys
and at the time that he's attending
these so-called club meetings as they
called him there were cases pending
before the Supreme Court
from the agencies that some of these
young men were working for where's this
photo from that photo is from the
reunion of the Grand Army of the
Republic that took place in the fall of
1936 and ten knocks this was Disney won
how tall is he buddy he looks like he's
taller and barely the guy he's standing
next to well yeah but the guy standing
next to is 94 years old and had fought
in the war and was somebody that knocks
it correspond with as far as I can tell
an ox is 5 9 or 5 times when you like
that and you have some calling card is
that one on the cover and there's one
here and you've actually brought a
couple of long I have indeed this was a
great surprise - knocks even though he
had a fairly active social life
certainly in Cambridge when he came to
Washington he was immediately told by
Justice McReynolds messenger Harry
Parker that you had to get calling cards
engraved those are the printed cards
there one is his professional card that
identifies him as law clerk to Justice
McReynolds and then the other is his own
personal calling card that just gives
the address of his residence and Knox
discovered very quickly that one of his
chief functions he says at one point in
the memoir that it was second only in
importance to opinion work at the court
was dealing with social invitations that
McReynolds received during the year in
dealing with the question of calling
cards because apparently during this
period Washington was a very strict
protocol about how you dealt with
calling cards and that is if you dropped
off a personal calling card at someone's
place and you were say Justice
McReynolds you turned up the right-hand
corner to indicate that you had done it
not your chauffeur if you just had your
chauffeur or your law clerk or somebody
do it you just left the card flat and
correspondingly when cards came into the
McReynolds residence it had an upturned
corner they got high priority attention
because the protocol again was that you
had 24 hours after receiving the card to
either acknowledge
not acknowledge it if you acknowledged
it then you're in that social circle now
am i right that he was born in 1900 and
died in 1997 1907 I'm sorry in 1907
that's right okay that would make him 90
that's right so in 1936 he would have
been his 29 turning 30 at the just after
the term ended how did he get his job as
the clerk or the secretary to justice
James McReynolds the short way of
putting it Brian has he talked his way
into it he developed a pen pal
relationship with justice Willis Van
Deventer and Van Deventer was someone
who had tangential associations with the
Civil War distant relatives who'd fought
in it but Van Deventer is great
attraction to Knox I think is that he
responded extensively to letters that
Knox wrote to him whoa I have no idea at
one point I say in the introduction that
it was either beguiled or bored you know
by this sick of vanish constant
letter-writing can you give me
professional advice is it appropriate to
refuse alcohol at professional parties
should a young lawyer get married
immediately upon beginning his career or
should he delay it the questions no one
would ask today out of the blue and
certainly not to a Supreme Court justice
just right out of the blue to out of
blue absolutely out of the blue and so
then how did he get the job well he
branchless the correspondence builds up
over a period of three or four years he
asked justice Van Deventer if and
Evander will serve as a reference for
him never met the man after he'd met him
he felt more comfortable in asking for a
reference and finally Van Deventer says
I know how I really can't do that but if
you're interested in working at the
court perhaps something have happened
and then nothing happens and then six
months later
Van Deventer writes a fairly formally
this isn't right near the end of Knox's
second year at the Harvard Law School
saying there might be an opening would
you be interested are you married what
you know your formal credentials and on
the day that knox takes his LLM from the
harvard law school he gets a letter from
Justice McReynolds not Van Deventer
McReynolds saying I understand you're
interested in a clerkship I have some
questions for you and could you meet me
in Washington on a certain date now
turns a pen pal relationship with
McReynolds into and with Van Deventer
into an interview with McReynolds and
McReynolds hires him you mentioned this
earlier but how many people worked for
justices back then usually only one
although a couple of the justices had a
second Clerk Cardozo for example used a
second person who really was a social
secretary but he had a law degree and
Chief Justice Hughes had two but the
rest of them work with one to get that
big Supreme Court building and very few
of the just as you say worked out of
their offices did Justice McReynolds
ever go to his office maybe once or
twice during the course of the entire
term what's this
that's where Justice McReynolds lived
its 2,400 North 16th Street it's now
called the Envoy still standing it's
still an apartment house at the time
that McReynolds lived there cabinet
secretaries members of Congress lived
there it's right across from Meridian
Hill Park and if you stand on the hill I
actually went over to look at the place
you can see the White House absolutely
right to 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue 16th
Street feeling of great confidence I
think to anybody who lived there it got
run down apparently during World War two
in after World War two and then was
refurbished about 20 years ago and then
you have a picture of not the actual
apartment but one that looks like it
where'd you get that those are available
in the library Congress so you can
actually view them online how many rooms
did Justice McReynolds have 13 was a
huge apartment complex it's now I've
been chopped up in the refurbishment I
understand you know and you know much
smaller ones but he had 13 entire rooms
was he married no hado never married
never married did he had many friends
well that's hard talking about
McReynolds now no no that's hard to say
about McReynolds one of the interesting
features to me of the memoir is Knox's
frustration at not being able to get
close to McReynolds he wants a mentoring
relationship he gets a little bit of
that when he calls in justice Cardozo he
doesn't get him from Van Deventer
who as soon as Knox comes to work for my
friend says I can't talk to you anymore
because it would be inappropriate for me
to give advice to someone who's working
for another member of the court the most
that one can tell particularly from the
memoir is that Justice McReynolds viewed
himself as quite a ladies man and had a
number of wealthy widows that he
socialized with played golf with
at the Chevy Chase Club it's been a fair
amount of time but so John Knox gets to
meet Justice McReynolds when and how and
what was that first meeting like the the
first meeting is in June of 1936 and
McReynolds interviews and decides that
he's appropriate for the job he's
graduate of Harvard Van Deventer said
well of him he's single and he doesn't
smoke and those are the critical
criteria as far as McReynolds is
concerned and I think Knox is
disappointed with the interview he gets
none of the raconteur ship that he
enjoyed with Van Deventer none of the
warmth and outreach that he had seen
from justice Cardozo who of course he
had also called on in the previous few
years what did they pay in those days
what did justice McGraw is paying well
there was a fair amount of discretion on
the part of the justices because is we
point out in the foreword a lot of
clerks stayed on for multiple years the
chief clerk the Chief Justice Hughes was
the one who worked for Chief Justice
Taft so he'd been around for eight or
nine years Knox was paid $2,400
by McReynolds and Harry Parker the
messenger told NOx that he just wasn't
going to be able to afford to live in
Washington at 2400 on 2400 now you
mentioned Harry Parker who was he Harry
Parker was technically the messenger to
Justice McReynolds paid by the court he
also acted as chauffeur he cooked the
justices lunch he did all his marketing
he did a fair amount of the evening
cooking and as one of the justices lady
friends said he did everything but
breathe for the justice and Mary Mary
digs no lecture no picture we scoured
how high and low and couldn't find one
was made and part-time cook and we say
in the introduction that one of the I
think many values of this memoir is it
recaptures not only a social Washington
in the 30s but African American
Washington Harry Parker's mother served
as a cook in the McKinley administration
he himself was a well known caterer
there are families who worked in the
african-american community in Washington
for years for the government giving
fabulous service but who are all but
invisible because of the staff position
this is off the subject but why did you
stick this photograph in here just to
show the unbroken links between past and
present who's in this picture on the
left is George Nye Bank who was a law
clerk to justice Jackson in 1952
Harry Parker's in the center and George
Nye banks Co Clark is on the right
William Rehnquist who clerked for
Justice Jackson 1952-53 and you say
Harry Parker eventually went to work for
justice Jackson that's right
as soon as McReynolds left the court
Harry Parker went to work for justice
Jack's who was pussy-willow pussy-willow
twas the name that Harry and Mary had
for Justice McReynolds why because they
wanted to be able to talk about the
justice and his lady friends and their
social schedules and not have the
justice
suddenly over here and be concerned
about what was being said so they had
nicknames for the Justice the justice
was pussy-willow John Knox was Shu
Phoenix what are these names come from I
have no idea
Shu Phoenix Shu Phoenix I have
absolutely no idea
then there was Madame Queen Madame Queen
was apparently the the number one
girlfriend
at that point very savage yes this is
sad but paint the picture I mean he's
hired for the job $2,400 a year where
does he work where does John Knox work
he works in the justices apartment that
2400 where does he live Moll cubicle he
lives downstairs at 2400 at least for
the first several months but it's
extremely expensive
he feels totally isolated I mean he's
living at a pretty rarified social
atmosphere in the building and he
eventually moves out to a place of 2,700
Connecticut Avenue one of the the
problems that Knox had going from this
busy social life that he had in
Cambridge to Washington is that he felt
isolated living in the building he
didn't know many people and the those
that he was most immediately exposed to
were within McReynolds circle and he
turned out to be fairly charming with
these widows that McReynolds socialized
with and Harry Park of warning me said
if the justice finds out about you
socializing
well his lady friends she's gonna fire
you on the spot and that creates kind of
a drama Oh done in the book about he
keeps warning him all the time
absolutely and of course as you know
eventually something happens that's
right the roof falls in well and there's
even a one beautifully dramatic moment
in which Knox is really attacking into
the wind and is attending one tea or
dinner this happens to be a tea that
mrs. savages apartment which is one
floor above McReynolds apartment and the
justice rolls up on a Sunday afternoon
unannounced and the only time it
happened only time it happened that
that's recorded and fortunately mrs.
Savage
made seasoned knows the country Tom
that's occurred and gets mrs. Savage to
scoot Knox and his friend out of the
apartment before Justice will seize them
well as he paints the scene he's not
sure that Justice McReynolds might have
seen him he's not sure but as time goes
on he's he doesn't think that much
Reynolds did now one of the things that
also pops up in the memoir is a name
famous name in jurisprudence Felix
Frankfurter and why is it that that name
keeps coming up well this is the New
Deal and Felix Frankfurter was all over
the New Deal in many respects he's a
professor of law at Harvard Law School
at the time that's the book covers and
his immediate contact with Knox is in a
course of 200 students called Public
Utilities and Knox gets his lowest grade
in law school from Felix Frankfurter but
he nonetheless manages to arrange the
Supreme Court clerkship for secretary
ship with Justice McReynolds
and that's astonishing it certainly
astonished as Justice Brandeis when Knox
calls on him as he did with almost all
of the justices and Brandeis says you
came from Harvard Law School and you
weren't sent by professor frankfurter
was frankfurter was essentially
recommending clerks to at least two of
not three of the justices he was sending
clerks on an annual basis to Justice
Brandeis as he had with Justice Holmes
he'd recommended Alger Hiss the Justice
Holmes for example and at this time he
was also sending clerks to justice
cardozo the Cardoza had so many friends
he operated kind of on a rota basis
Harvard Yale Columbia now what dear was
Felix Frankfurter appointed the court
1939 and did he take Justice Brandeis as
place no justice Douglas took Brandeis
is boys and what year did he live leave
it they all it all happens at once black
comes on in 37 read about the same time
and then Douglas in Frankfurt 39 and it
just it all happens in a whoosh
basically after this termination but of
all the things that attend this memoir
what did you personally get the biggest
kick out well it wasn't one particular
incident it was watching this guy I
worked at the Supreme Court as a law
clerk in the mid-1970s different Warren
elationship justice Byron white
everybody worked in the building there
were three clerks for each justice and I
was fascinated to see how self-absorbed
Knox was and how much he was leaning on
any of the justices but particularly his
own justice for a mentoring relationship
and that wasn't an expectation I had
when I went to work at the Supreme Court
maybe some people do I suppose but the
way you're on that point to explain how
many times John Knox 29 years old clerk
to Justice McReynolds anti-semite and
racist met with other justices just 40
well he did it as far as I can tell from
the memoir and everything else that I've
been able to dig up justice Butler and
justice Sutherland were the only
justices that he didn't see during the
year and again Harry Parker tells him
what are you doing going over to see
Brandeis going over to see Cardoso you
shouldn't do that
they're both juries both Joyce
McReynolds gonna find out about that he
will fire you on the spot but you know
this is this is how Knox got the job in
the first place
and it's what he saw the payoff has been
now justice Cardozo who was he and
there's a picture of him what year did
he die 1938 he didn't live much longer
than the period that the book covers
what was his claim to fame well he was
more famous frankly as a state court
judge he was chief judge of the New York
Court of Appeals throughout the 1920s
named to the Supreme Court by Herbert
Hoover in 1932 to replace Justice Holmes
and serves from 32 to 38 but his real
claim to fame
is for opinions that helped to
revolutionize the law of contract the
law of tort especially there's personal
injury sorts of things he was most
famous for that and he wrote a few
important opinions as a Supreme Court
justice but he wasn't around long enough
to have much of an impact and he was in
the minority for much of the time he was
on the court he writes two important
opinions in this term involving the
constitutionality of the Social Security
Act you say that Justice McReynolds told
the John Knox when he was in the house
no smoking no lady friends right no
green eyeshade that's right in the 1930s
and this apparently persisted into the
1940s because when I was doing my book
on Byron white I discovered that he wore
a green eyeshade when he was at Yale Law
School in the early 1940s apparently
this was something that was done in
those days and Knox continues to do that
as a way of keeping the glare off and
McReynolds sees it on one of the first
days on the job and what is that and
Knox tells him in McReynolds says I
never want to see it again get rid of it
so their little crutches in the little
habits that Knox brought to the job or
kind of extinguished one by one by the
Justice I got to read this incident on
page 89 of this diary and this is John
Knox writing a few moments later harry
formally conveyed this request to me
though I had already overheard the
justices conversation then with a
grimace and pointing silently toward the
bathroom with his finger Harry walked
back into the dining room I knew what he
meant so I tiptoed silently past the
open door of McReynolds bathroom before
going downstairs to the garage I could
scarcely believe what I saw water seemed
to be a quarter of an inch deep on the
floor and it was spliced all over the
walls to bath towels were tossed
carelessly on the side of the tub
instead of being hung up in their proper
places everything in fact seemed to be a
complete wreck as if a tornado had just
passed through the room there's a lot of
detail before that but what did he talk
justise rental McReynolds apparently was
a very sloppy bathroom and it's I was
astonished when I came across that part
of the manuscript I must say this is
Knox arriving very early one morning
thing was probably the opening day of
the court and he hears noises emanating
from the bathroom sloshing and all that
sort of thing going on and then he
surveys the wreckage afterwards so
Justice McReynolds lived alone but dined
alone lived alone and dined alone what
were then sets up the circumstances of
how the whole dining thing worked well
he had a large dining room you know
these were large rooms and well fixed
apartments and he had a formal dining
room table that he used for Sunday
brunches and the like and occasionally
when he would have dinners in the
evening but his normal dinners were at a
small table in the dining room where he
ate alone and where he was served by
Harry Parker who stood a few feet away
from him and cleared the dishes as each
course was completed the phone call is
the justice in came a sweet sounding
feminine voice over the wire that story
and Knox totally blows it
oh is this mrs. X and it turns out to be
mrs. Y and mrs. X is absolutely furious
and when Knox admits to McReynolds that
he's made a mistake McReynolds can't
believe it
they can't believe that anybody would be
so stupid and presumptuous at the same
time but the scene on a day-to-day basis
what did the justice require of John
Knox in the way of coming to work and
what his responsibility was while he was
at work arrived by 9 o'clock in the
morning and no later be there all day so
if I call and I need you you can do
whatever needs to be done leave by 6
o'clock
unless I let you go earlier or I need
you later and the first order of
business was to pick up the mail from
downstairs in the lobby of 2400 to bring
it to him to answer all social
invitations immediately according to the
justices direction and
proceeded to whatever court work was
imperative and what kind of rules were
there about who answers the telephone
well they two telephones they had one
that was a private line that went
straight to the justices study and then
there was the public line it was the
public line that this telephone call
came in and I believe what's the story
of the march of time filling and filming
well as the president's court packing
plan is getting more publicity because
it essentially fractures the New Deal it
splits the coalition some support at
some point so it's getting a lot of
attention so the march of time which was
essentially the principal newsreel of
the day wants photo footage of all the
justices and hughes Chief Justice Hughes
knows that McReynolds will be the
problem because he's the one who's least
sympathetic to journalists and so the
arrangement is if everyone else can be
photographed they will go to McReynolds
and McReynolds said he would consider
being photographed if everyone else was
photographed first well the problem was
that the criminals never gave a firm
commitment to be photographed and Knox
let the march of time into 2400 where
they set up with lots of lights and
cables and reflectors and that sort of
thing and Mike Reynolds arrived home and
wasn't prepared for it and essentially
throw a fit and this is recounted in the
Pearson Allen book the nine old men as
an example of McReynolds testiness and
bad manners got a letter that you
republish in here page 99 what's the
circumstance you have to refresh my
memory I don't it's a letter from one of
his lady friends in society go on and
read it we can now always hear his key
turning in the door if he should come
home but he ain't going to be getting
here soon in other words John Knox is
this letter he's picking up to read it
but I shouldn't read his letter Mary
unless he wants me to is this one that
I'm supposed to answer what difference
will
make he'll never know now Willie and
besides he left it's sitting right here
on the top of the desk where I'd be
Dustin anyway if he didn't read it
you remember this yet yeah I'll read the
letter yeah that's it's an example of
the corners that Harry Marion knocks
were constantly cutting in dealing with
the justice and I think the justice is
basically on to them he knows if he
leaves some fun pelvis to us he's going
to get read by the entire staff Mary's
read his will which he left out on the
desk which she talks about letters like
that there's this little private game
that seems to be going on between
McReynolds and the House staff on almost
a constant base I mean letter in the
segment how old would you say Mary was
at the time my best guess is 40s early
50s she's a black black maid right and
Harry's the black messenger is the
technical I say black because it's
clearly important in McReynolds life and
John Knox would be as we said 29 dear Mr
Justice is what's his letter they opened
it up all right
how very nice it was to hear from you
especially since it was so lonely to be
laid up in the hospital but I'm feeling
quite fitting in and hope to go home
soon the head doctor on the floor must
have sensed my loneliness as he has been
in a number of times to talk with me on
one pretext or another but he is a Jew
it's obvious imagine I really did not
know what to make of him at first but I
was of course repelled he even touched
me with his hands what lengths these
Jews will go to in order to make a
conquest and I certainly never expected
one of them to turn up here in this
hospital a number of his lady friends
shared his biases and I mean that's the
way he felt I mean is there more
evidence that he felt that way
well not other than the stories that
I've recounted to you today he was just
he was blatant about it so what how did
he if he wouldn't have his picture taken
with Louis Brandeis right and everybody
knew he was anti-semitic did anybody
ever ask him why or did
ever know didn't want to confront him
there's a story which I've never been
able to verify that the Chief Justice
Hughes said something to him after the
incident at justice cardozo swearing-in
when he was reading the newspaper
- which McReynolds supposedly replied I
don't work for you
you know that's there's the sense that
Chief Justice of the United States
simply presides the Prima center Paris
in name only that each one of those
people life tenure answers only two
again Justice McReynolds was on the
court from 1914 to why forty-one died in
46 was from Kentucky where did he go to
law school the University of Virginia
which he did their law course in 14
months 14 just blew through it and you
say there's a footnote in it he suggests
that even though he was really seriously
opposed to the court packing thing that
he had originally suggested this whole
idea of packing courts 1913 well he he
actually made a suggesting to President
Wilson of focusing more on the lower
courts than on the Supreme Court that
incentives be generated to get judges to
retire in that if they wouldn't retire
that something like this be implemented
what do you think of John Knox I mean
what did it whatever mounted what day is
the rest of his life well he writes in
his diary he resumes his diary in the
1960s and he writes in 1963 that I'm a
pathetic failure at this point did he
ever marry never married lived where for
the rest of his life well he moved back
to Chicago they worked as a lawyer he
flunked the bar several times before he
was admitted to practice he worked in
New York for a while during World War
two then he moved back to Chicago
actually back to his family's residence
in Oak Park after the war to take over
his father's business which was
beginning
and he ran that business as well as he
could even rewrote some of his father's
little salesman chat books for a while
but the business went belly-up in the
early 1950s and so he became an
insurance adjuster for Allstate the
duck-hunting and what Harry had to do
during the duck-hunting of Justice
McReynolds Harry had to be the dog there
twice there is a reference or an account
to McReynolds going out to the Eastern
Shore to hunt ducks in the fall and
taking Harry with him and Harry's job
was to retrieve the kill the wade
through icy waters and bring back the
Ducks and there was a very poignant
moment in which Harry says I'm getting
too old to do this I'm gonna get
pneumonia I wish you wouldn't do that
it's just the most demeaning image and
Knox is totally affected by it he's he's
really offended it's it's one thing to
talk about the bigotry or any semitism
and I'm in a public or direct sense but
doing this to a staff member it just
obviously curdles not stomach another
thing that plays out through the entire
Diary is that during that year Harry
kept telling him you better never you
better be here every time the justice
calls absolutely right why well the
Justice was notorious for having bad
labor relations with his secretaries
they did intended not to last for very
long he was very moody
he could be peremptory could be
arbitrary and Harry tries to explain
this to Knox and says you know he wants
you here and if you're not here he'll
fire you on the spot and he says that
several times Harry is worried all year
that Knox is gonna get fired either for
socializing with the justices lady
friends or being absent from the
apartment where he should be to answer
the telephone if there's an official
call or if the Justice himself calls and
as the Year wears on particularly as the
bar examination gets closer and closer
Knox is spending more time away from the
apartment studying for the bar and the
air-condition quarters of the
Supreme Court building then Harry warns
him again he says you better be around
here what were they did today the court
meets the ten o'clock in the morning
when I here's an oral argument but what
in those days wanted at me they tended
to meet at noon and how many arguments
are they here a day two or three and
then they had because they had a break
there for lunch because that's what Knox
would go out knowing that if he was back
at what time usually just before they
started the session you know whenever it
happened to be it depend on how many
arguments they had that day but you have
a scenario in here also about an opinion
that he dictated to John Knox which
prevented him from going to a White
House reception well what's that story
well there are a couple of examples in
the memoir of the kind of gratuitous
cruelty one is on a fairly low level
where he assigns Knox an opinion to
write in Knox writes four drafts of it
spent the entire weekend doing it takes
up a Sunday doing it and Harry tells him
you're wasting your time justice ain't
going to use it he's just trying to keep
you busy and Knox is trying to prove
himself or maybe to reassure the Justice
that they can do a job and sure enough
when the justice gets back it takes the
opinion tosses in the wastebasket
the other time the reference that I
think you've just brought up is the
Justice it goes on and on working on an
opinion dictating so that Knox will be
hard-pressed to attend a reception at
the White House that's the annual
reception for the judiciary and Knox has
gone to lengths to get his tuxedo
cleaned and pressed
and it's very eager to do it but by the
time McReynolds finishes dictating the
opinion that's just too late and Knox is
sure that McReynolds staged it that way
when FDR announced the court packing
bill it was just three hundred and forty
second press conference February the 5th
1937 correct John Knox was still there
absolutely Justice McReynolds is on the
court and then strange things happened I
mean can you paint they the
court reacted very strangely to that
well the court did react strangely to it
I think one of the action historical
facts that the memoir contributes is the
sense that several members of the court
had a foreboding that the president is
going to do something after the election
NOx recounts in his memoir I've
discovered carbon copies of letters he
wrote to his family saying the Justin
this is before February 5th the Justice
is very nervous
he's afraid something's going to happen
he's been talking to a stockbroker he's
been talking to advisors in New York
he's afraid he's going to be forced off
the court and then the court packing
plan is announced on the fifth and the
courts response is twofold the Chief
Justice of the United States agrees to
provide a letter to senator Burton
wheeler on the Senate Judiciary
Committee that essentially takes the
president head-on in saying we're up to
date in our business we don't need more
people the court is fully abreast of its
work the other thing the court does is
slow down and Justice McReynolds as part
of that they just don't issue any
significant opinions for a period about
two and a half months because they have
the power to issue the opinions whenever
they want to one of the things it's hard
to believe is with only one real you
know substantive person working for him
in the clerkship that he never ever
talked to him about any of these cases
and you say in here that memoir says
that Justice McReynolds never talked to
John Knox about the court packing bill
never talked about the court packing
bill never talked about the most
controversial New Deal cases the
constitutionality of the National Labor
Relations Act you know was the huge case
or set of cases in fact never discussed
it and Knox was obviously hurt by that I
think that's one of the reasons he
recounts it in the memoir but to
McReynolds you know why should he talk
to a staff member about that he knew
what he thought one of the things that's
interesting Brian issue kind of compare
the the courts workload and output as we
were talking about earlier
as they wrote a lot shorter opinions in
those days you'll notice an ox will
recount from time to time the opinion
takes up five pages in the u.s. reports
14 pages and the others reports
well the school vouchers opinions this
term are more than 100 pages by the time
to get everybody's opinions out again
but geez but he says basically I get the
impression that john knox never ever
wrote an opinion i think that's accurate
as far as I can tell it's different than
today much different from today did you
used to write opinions I worked on
opinions absolutely wrote drafts and the
Justice would revise them Chief Justice
Rehnquist has talked about that in his
confirmation hearings and in his books
so I give my clerks 10 days to write an
opinion one of the things that John Knox
has really started lower his opinion of
Justice McReynolds was the Kings
abdication speech on the radio now what
king and well this is the King King
Edward who was abdicating his throne for
the woman I love Wallis Warfield Simpson
and the abdication speech at the time
was the most listened to radio address
in history and Knox was sure that the
justice would allow Harry Mary and him
to listen to it on the radio and they're
all getting ready to do it and when they
finally asked permission the justice
said no it won't be heard tonight in
this house and then John Knox one day
finds himself invited to lunch by Harry
and Mary and what happens well this is
as the the term is worn on it's about
halfway through the term and they
obviously get along very well again this
is Knox's account it's it's a memoir you
know I can't verify every single word of
it by any means but it rings true and
Harry and Mary said and once you join us
for lunch
Mary says I'll throw an extra pork chop
on the fire he saw that that would be
wonderful he's very lonely at this point
and so the meal is cooked
and two tables are set up in the kitchen
one for Harry and Mary and one for Knox
it knocks ease the two tables and can't
believe it
you know this is how far segregation
operates in Washington and in this
household these Wi-Fi King to that I'll
sit with you and Mary is kind of thrown
by that but eventually the three of them
sit down at the same table together
there's a trip to West Point early very
early in the term Knox goes on a driving
trip with Justice McReynolds to West
Point and on their way back they visit
the Gettysburg battlefield the interest
in that trip to me was that it and
there's actually a photograph in the
book that Knox took during that trip of
the Justice lounging in an armchair
there it is the interest in that trip to
me other than just a glimpse of
McReynolds out of his habitat is that
for the first time the justices
tenderness toward children comes through
he sees a woman and her child and says
that would make a lovely picture would
you mind if my secretary took your
picture and Knox who at that time says
he always traveled with camera took a
lot of pictures and when they were
developed they were satisfactory as the
word that Knox uses in the Justice sent
copies to the woman a couple of entire
remaining a couple of funerals happened
it was a justice cardozo that died and
in McReynolds did not go to the funeral
was justice brandeis I can't remember it
was justice cardozo he just didn't go
didn't go but when he died what happened
well when he died the only
representative of the court was the
marshal Thomas Waggaman no justice
attended the funeral did he have any
friends at tennis here
he had friends from Elkton kentucky who
attended the funerals six businessmen
from Elkton were the pallbearers but the
only representative the Supreme Court of
the United States was the marshal Jamie
idea what I'm did John Knox
1997 well I know a little bit about the
funerals we recount in the afterward it
was attended by they've been chilled you
bliss would been his caregivers and one
of the plus children and a couple of
people in Oak Park and an
african-american minister provided even
though there was a confederate flag
draped over the coffin Dennis Hutchinson
works where at the University of Chicago
what do you do there I teach them to
college and then the law school like
it's a constitutional law and legal
history how long have you been there
this is my 21st year how long did it
take you to get this book published by
the University of Chicago
well once we had what we were satisfied
was the final manuscript they got it out
in very short order less than a year do
you know what year this picture of John
Knox was taken I think it's 1952 or 1953
I'm not sure it's the reason we
published it was twofold one is that
it's about the time you started writing
the memoir and the other is as a bookend
to the child of promise age 7 that you
showed earlier you said that you clerked
for justice Byron white what year 75 76
where did you get your law degree well I
have two but no JD and it's sad and an
interesting story I did one year at the
University of Chicago Law School then I
went to England for three years and then
English law degree at Oxford and then
came back and did an LLM at the
University of Texas at Austin where did
you get your undergraduate Bowdoin
College and Maine yeah and where are you
from originally Colorado where in
Colorado Boulder and are you writing
another book I'm trying to get to one
I've got too many little projects but I
want to return to a project I started a
long time ago on justice Jackson on his
unpublished opinions Robert Jackson
we're at a time editor of this co-editor
this book with David Garrow is Dennis
Hutchinson and here's what the cover
looks like it's the Forgotten memoir of
John Knox 1936 thank you very much sir
thank you